hey everyone I'm Lou so I'm going to
share the topic about how to maximize
our GPZ for model
training I see ex that same introduction
as James have
introduced so uh so first I briefly
introduce what is the alasio data
platform you can consider it as one is
like a high performance data assess and
the other hand is able to connect to
different storage system so basically if
brings the data of different storage
system closer to different Frameworks
like the big data Frameworks like Spar
Presto and also the AI Frameworks like
pyou and tensor Pro so it bring the data
closer and provide high performance data
access so for the functionality side it
have different aspect the several main
aspect is that it provide distributed
caching capability it provide the global
data access and then data management in
including like some data
migration so on this session we will
briefly talk about some of the high
level design of impementation of this uh
aasal data
platform so uh this for first uh comes
with like actually the problem of like
um from many of the model chaining uh
jobs we actually found that data
locality become the issue it's esally
when those training job they need to get
the really huge data set in their
storage system ready in their training
system and and also like in these cases
like many of the training World loads
they are running in kuet cluster which
is the aggregated from their Cloud story
systems their story system may be like
Cloud story system like either S3 Eder
blog storage or the Google cloud storage
and all is like on per data storage like
hdfs or sth and how to make those huge
data set in their storage system ready
for their training is become a problem
of that and so consider every time you
go through the whole network to get the
data ready it's like the latency may be
really low and the through Pro latency
may be really high and and the through
Pro may be really low and this will
directly result in a low J utilization
rate and also for many chaining jobs
they use the same data set again and
again so every time we need to fetch the
whole data set from the storage system
to the chaining jobs it kind of like
have a really high storage cost for data
transfer fee because every data that
transfer from the storage system to the
training job it costs money like from
other Cloud
vendors and there are multiple solutions
to solve this problem so first part is
that um the users just as I mentioned
before you can always fetch the entire
data set from remote storage on the fly
but the repeat uh fetching the data set
from the remote storage is become it may
like lowering the data loading
performance and also lowering the GP
utilization rate or you can copy the
data set from remote to local before
chaining however this approach really
requires that the whole data set can be
fit in your local disk which which may
not be the case in many of the training
wallows the training wallows the GPU
clusters they may not have this
available or their this have a limited
capability and the other way is to have
a local cach layer for data reuse so we
still need to f a data set from the
remote storage but we can catch the most
hot data in the local so that we can
reuse them in the next round however
like in many of the training worlds we
we use the same data set from Appo to
appoc however the uh however this is
from the cluster level but if you
consider it from the single node level
we may not reuse the full data set the
there will be data shuffling between
each appoc so that the data reviews rate
probably like only 10% or even less so
only limited benefit can be provided by
this local cach
layer so there is some also some
distribut catching approaches basically
like we can uh cat the data in a
distribut system which can store much
more cach data compared to the local
cach and this is one of the ways that
many caching system do before so we have
the master and worker uh architecture so
Master basically is the brain of the
whole cluster but it also become the
single P of failure it provides you all
the data manager functionality but you
also are on the critical path of each
read or write request so basically if
the master done you the whole cluster
are not able to serve any request and
will results in your training job to
actually fell and on the other hand this
master uh worker architecture made the
master become the performance bottleneck
of the overall performance so uh
consider like each of the request you
need to talk to master to say that hey I
want to read this file and then you need
to talk to worker to actually get that
file then asking the master you want to
get a file or asking the location of
that file becomes the performance botton
now in the AI chaining JW the JW is
easily can exed like tens of thousand
square per second so if every time it go
to the master then Master will
definitely become the Bottom now even a
huge machine are not able to serve like
tens or hundreds of
QPS so another way that we are doing now
is using cons hashing to cat both data
and medata on workers so basically we
remove the single P of failure and we
remove the performance bottle net now
client directly knows that which worker
that she should ask like data and
metadata too and then directly connect
with that worker so and but we also keep
the data managing system basically we
still have the um many features like how
can we M migrate data from one star
system to other and Etc we still have a
visibility of like what is in the
cluster however there's some new
challenges happening the first one
because like client directly connect to
worker to catching data and fetch the
catch data then there's a direct problem
that what if the worker low is
imbalanced maybe one worker they store
more data and the that worker also serve
more clients then that worker will be
super busy and While others being idle
and in this case the overall performance
may be hurted and it will also lead to
outages and way to solve is is that it's
called the Affinity caching solution so
we optimize that with affinity cashing
so users they can configure how many
replicas they want to cash they want to
cash one or three Etc and we will use
the consistent hashing to determine the
first choice no for cashing so like we
will first go to this first choice note
to see that hey do you have the data and
are you able to serve me and if they are
not you just go to another note another
uh waiter and see that whether they can
serve you and then if not you go to the
serve one so this is basically the logic
if all notes are super busy then we will
always fall back to the cloud storage
and we will directly ask the cloud
storage to provide the data set and so
when you're reading from the catching
system it just like find the first no
and then get the data and then find the
second Noe if the first Noe fa but
usually in most of cases the first note
should be able to serf request and this
way is to prevent the noes become super
busy and provide prevent the balance in
maybe like less than 10%
scenarios and now we are going to share
about how we actually ma maximize DB
utilization and Microsoft shopy J and
many other our
users this is a typical like large
language model pipeline that uh we now
we found that many of our users they are
not they don't have a single CL they
actually have have multiple Cloud to
provide to prevent the uh Cloud vendor
locking so and they also have different
chaining and serving jobs and different
clouds and really depends on like the
price of their GPU machines and the the
the resources Etc so but it results in
the on the rra side that they have
different training jobs different
serving jobs they are not collocated
together and so that we found there's SE
several problems in this architecture so
uh on the left side we have a model
chaining job that running pyou and then
it need to fetch the data from the
object storage and in this way the
chaining job need to repeatedly fash in
the same data set from the storage
system and a really high concurrent
request and it will have two
consequences like the first one is that
because the changing job uh need to fet
data remotely if the data loading maybe
tastes more than more time than isy and
it may become the training job
bottleneck it will result in low GP
lization rate on the other hand the
storage system may have a huge pressure
so there are two ways that they handle
that for many of the cloud storage they
basically give you a request rate limit
if you exceed that request rate limit
basically you have errors when you
reading the data and depends on whether
your training jobs handle those errors
well it may actually affect your
training job stability on the other hand
uh for some oner storage system if you
put a highly concurrent wallows onto
your storage system it may put your
story system at risk and they may so
there are many times that when we talk
to some our users their data team will
actually yell at their training team
saying that you guys affect our
stability and you put us at risk and can
you gu start doing that because for the
oner storage they need to make sure
their data is safe they need to make
sure their existing right wallow and
their existing other long running
reallow function as normal so if there
was a circumstances that the training
jobs T all their capability of serving
request then they cannot serve other
requests well and may it may result in a
much severe scen uh
circumstances on the other hand there
are also the serving closture the
serving closture their request is to
deploy the model quickly to all the
serving nodes so the quicker that we
deploy the models the quicker we are
able to see the actual business impacts
and if the model does not work as is B
we also need to quickly roll back to the
previous version so have a way to
quickly deploy the new model and quickly
revert to the older models are critical
for the inference
classroom and their solution is
basically they put a catching layer
between the chaining uh jobs serving
jobs and also the stor system so on the
chaining JW side uh they can use this
catching system to F the data from
remote storage catching it locally and
provide the data set to their chaining
job so that the data set only be need to
fet from Storage once and following uh
request will be served by alasio and
also on the other hand like because data
is much closer to the chaining ofs it
can provide much lower latency and much
higher through Pro and basically it can
improve the overall DP utilization rate
and on the other hand on the serving
cluster side we can help uh fetch the
model into alasio as a model storage
then uh the the models only been loaded
from alasio to all changing noes and
this can provide much faster model
loading compared comped to loading
always C across the network to the
remote story
system basically uh from the business
side it can aeve like two to four times
faster than to Market on the technical
benefit side it's it can increase the GP
utilization
rate and we do have several benchmarks
that showing uh how we can and Achieve
like those performance benefits using
different computer Frameworks the first
Benchmark is using pyou and alasio we
launch alasio wire kubernetes basically
we provide caching for the training data
the all the training jobs and the alasio
system is launched directly in the CIS
cluster and they are either collocated
or near each other and we use some
popular de learning algorithms and de
learning data set like the ret and image
net and we have some visualization
dashboard a pretty
standard um Benchmark that we
did okay so basically this is the S scre
that we do the AI machine learning
training it's pretty standard just
similar to how you guys did the rnap uh
res 50 on the image now that's it and so
yeah everything is pretty
standard and now we start running the
Benchmark and one critical P here is the
data preparation so basically like
alasio turns your storage data set into
a local path to be consumed by the
training jobs so for here you can see
the data path is just a local path under
an elocal fields and we provide this
local data path to the stor to the
training jobs so that it can consume the
data from this local path and allas you
on the backend help fet the data set
from the remote storage catching it in a
distributed system and then provide high
performance data access to all the
training
wallow and we do the typical like touch
data loader
under uh and the rnet 50 chaining
everything is just as uh what the
industrial do and it's nothing
surprise and then we finish the
training and we can look at the tens so
for tens there are two key points here
and the first one is the data loader
rate we can see the data loader rate is
only like
0.54% and it directly result in a high G
utilization rate of more than
90% And there are also some dashboard
that's showing that how many of the
operations is Heat against alasio is
Hash heat and how many of them actually
go to the remote storage
Etc so uh we we basically compare this
this Benchmark to from using data cach
in alasio compared to the same region S3
so when the training directory load the
data from same region S3 more than 80%
of the total time is spent in data
loader and directly result in a really
low deputization rate Which is less than
% and when you guys see similar like
graph like this that's the time that you
may consider adding a catching system
depends on how how big is a data set you
may consider like using a distributed
catching system or another way of a
share
wall and after using alasio training
with alasio reduce the data loader rate
from 82% to 1% and it increased the GPU
utilization rate from 177% to 93%
% okay that's for the pyou part uh we
also have some Benchmark about the ray
for some of you guys that may not be
familiar with Ray so Ray is basically a
duty scheduler it helps you to schedule
your chaining job together with some
preparation steps so basically you can
schedule your data loading data
pre-processing and chaining jobs
together to fully utim your GPU and CPU
resources and alaso position in the AI
ecosystem is that like comp rate as a
UniFi Compu machine learning pilot
alation it ring around show the computer
framework like pyou and tensor flow and
between pyou and tensor flow they need
to F the data from remote storage and
alaso can add as a high performance data
address layer between the computer
framework and the star
assistance and we do some of the
Benchmark using the ray Nal task which
is uh is published in their public G
report and so that uh compare with a
same region S3 alasio can provide T the
through Pro compared to same region S3
and really depends on how far away is
your chaining job with your storage
system for example if your uh your story
system if a remote As buy or your your
story system is really far away on p a
story system in another region it may
provide much more benefits compared to
this and this is actually one of the
worstest scenario that we can compare
with compar with cing using elas we as
the same region as three and another
thing we found that's pretty
interestingly is that when R object
start is under memory pressure the
performance Gap WI
the throughput of alasio with five times
that of S3 in these
scenarios so alasio can help catching
the data set for the ray framework Ray
did really good job of managing the ray
task data and but it doesn't uh deal
with the repeated data assess issue so
in the when you use R to do the chaining
job it will still repeatedly fetch the
data set from remote storage and when
you're using allasio to utilize the on
use this resources for the catching
capability it do improve the data
loading
performance and this is another one that
is more focusing on the serving BS this
is one of the screenshot that our user
share to us so that they use alasio to
achieve 10 as acceleration in model
deployment so on the left side you can
see the bars that's the bars is that
when they didn't use aaso how much me
how how long time do they need actually
to deploy their models
and the middle is like when they first
deploy alasio how much time they
actually need to deploy models and we
can see that deploying alaso immediately
like achieve only one third of the time
that needed to deploy their models and
on the right side we do some Coe
optimization with them and immediately
that we can reduce the model deployment
time to only one tenth of the original
Time by removing the unneeded the IPC C
and doing some like data assess
optimization that's we can achieve that
performance okay so we will move back to
the uh technical part again so it talk
about how we actually integrate with the
computer framework because there are
many of the storage system but uh how
can those storage system integrate with
the computer framework is this through
some of the storage specific apis or is
through some other apis what's the
connection way is better to achieve the
best performance for computer
Frameworks so this along with the whole
alasio technology Journey so in the
beginning alasio is open source started
from UC berkly m in
2014 and at that time we focusing on the
big data and analytics Frameworks like
spark prto and etc for those framework
in the hadu ecosystem the key API is the
hadu API so hadu API is the top the
first citizen API for for the story
system in the Hardo ecosystem and later
on uh we move to Cloud adoption move to
multic Cloud cross region and a little
bit of AI and that's the to that poses
API really shines because the users they
just want to use alasio as a local
folder they don't want to make any
changes to their what LO their screens
and Etc so that have a huge need for the
posess API and recently when the whole
AI shines and the whole basically all
the computer Frameworks like the
especially the AI Frameworks they have
built around python then python API
become the first citizen API in this
whole scenario and compared to posess
API which is highly I would say highly
uncontrollable so posst this API is
developed basically around the colonal
cause and it's not designed for AI uh
then it have a lot of behavior that is
not Target for high concurrent like data
assess if you have like high confir data
assess they basically they will launch
their own through to deal with request
they double the CPU requirement for
those requests and also like they have
like a lot of UN need the RPC costs for
example when you are reading a a file it
will have random number of get file stat
cost and each G file ST cost May ruin
your performance and so that when we
move to the AI first is that like the
whole ecosystem is built around
Ai and also like the python API is much
more comp like controllable from a
developer perspective and from
performance perspective compared to
poess API so that's the direction that
we are
going so one of the main thing that uh
we see many of computer framework they
share the thing is that um the computer
framework basically many of them are
moving towards py Arrow project so P
project did a really great job in the
format translation so you can read data
from whatever like format to Arrow
format and if you need another format
you just transfer the arrow form format
to that format uh and it also helps you
to produce your data set basically
whatever format that you are using in
your computer framework you can return
it back to Arrow or you turn it back to
the format that you like like pet format
and then persisted in the storage
system and P Arrow do a really good job
in the kind of the format translation
and but it delicate the storage
interface the storage connection part to
another open source project called file
system back I love that project it did a
really good job it basically using that
project you can be able to assess all
the story system that you want like from
the public Cloud story to all the op on
even to some private story system that
provided by datab bre or snowflake so
everything that the all the famous like
story system that you can think of they
they implement the file systems back and
it basically turn that storage system
API to a uniform pyo python iio like
interface that can easily be consumed by
all the application including bom
limited to P
Arrow there are many cases they just
don't need P Arrow they just want to
lower data set or lower model from
random storage system that they directly
use file system B to do that data
faction
assessing
and aaso in this picture as as a super
catching layer for file sist back
basically like when file sist back they
will fash the data from the remote
storage system into alasio and then
catch it in alasio and when they have
served some re request they basically
first come to alasa to say that hey do
you have the data that I want if you
have that's great it's much closer it's
much easier I just still get it and Che
my users but if you don't have it I go
to the story system to fetch it for you
and then put a copy in this super
catching
layer and so that together I can even
have more uh insights about like how
much data I actually read from the story
system how much data is actually served
by the catching system and what's the
hottest data basically they also ask
some like uh data visibility into what
data you actually use and how much of
the data is actually the hot data set in
in all the compute
worlds and not that like all the
framework they can share the catching
layer instead of like for the F building
cat functionality is per note level
basically is per framework per note
level you cannot reuse it across
different nodes you cannot use it across
different Frameworks but adding a super
catching layer those things are can be
reused and this is a a pretty simple
example of like how you can assess like
S3 storage just like a python IO local
file system you can do the allasio ls
allasio open and read B pretty similar
to what you use the python I
library and when you integrate with some
of the computer Frameworks like Ray in
this case originally the line is the
ray. data. r image and you get in the S3
URL and now you just need to pass in
file system into allasio to add that
super catching
layer I think that's it uh for the whole
talk and feel free to use your question
in the chat I think we oh I can't
running out the time like only one
minute left if anybody have any question